we begin this newshour with breaking
news the russian defense minister says
moscow's forces have taken control of
the city of lissa chance ukraine's last
major stronghold in the eastern donbass
region let's bring in alan fisher
joining us from key what more are we
hearing about this fight for religious
chance gallon
this happening just in in the last few
minutes certainly the russians and the
russian-backed separatists have been
saying that they encircled this city for
the last 24 hours or so a claim that has
been denied by the ukrainians but the
fact that this is coming from moscow
itself would suggest that there's some
credibility to that claim and they're
now fighting inside the city itself this
is an important significant strategic
city because it is the last ukrainian
stronghold in the donbass area and in
the lacance region uh it's certainly it
would be a major victory for the
russians a major blow for the ukrainians
uh the ukrainians we haven't been able
to get any official confirmation from
them yet
but they are aware of the pressure that
has been put on the city over the last
48 hours or so by russian forces and
kremlin-backed separatists and that
would be a concern that finally uh
they've not been able to stop the
encirclement of the city and the the
forces from russia moving into the city
streets where
as the russians say they are now
fighting all right alan you'll keep us
across this developing story but let me
ask you about ukraine uh being accused
of shelling a russian city
that's right we're talking about the
city of belgorod uh overnight the the
mayor there said there were a number of
explosions reported that it appeared
that the air defenses had been activated
number of buildings have been destroyed
at the last count four people had been
killed and he said an investigation is
underway but some politicians not
waiting for that investigation making it
very clear that they believe ukraine is
responsible for that and saying that
they should pay a very severe price for
what they've done this would be
embarrassing for the ukrainians if they
targeted at civilian area given over the
last few days they have made a very big
deal about the fact that they believe
the russians have been targeting
civilian areas not least a shopping
center just a few days ago and then of
course an apartment block in odessa and
friday where 21 people were killed there
and in a recreation center and even
vladimir putin himself said that they
were not targeting civilians that the
russian military had the wherewithal to
be able to find out where the military
targets were and target them precisely
so the ukrainians will now come under
pressure not to target uh or hit uh
civilian areas as well and certainly
humanitarian organizations who since the
very start of this war have urged both
sides to avoid civilian areas we'll be
re emphasizing the fact that civilians
have to be protected in this conflict
all right thank you so much alan
fisher's reporting from kiev